Existe uma grande diferença entre a vó
do rico e a vó do pobre primeiro o nome
o nome eu já pararei PR prestar atenção
que é muito diferente eu fui na casa do
amigo meu um dia desse que é rico nome
da vó do cara é Andreia Andreia você é
nome de vó Andreia ser sincero PR você
eu não confio num bolo de uma vó chamada
Andreia Eu não confio vó que chama
Andreia certeza faz aqueles bolos massa
pronta sabe só bate e bota Ó vó de
verdade chama nome de velho cara neid
Amélia Marle a vó do cara chamava André
o vô do cara chamava Pablo isso não é
nome de vô meu Deus do céu um cara
chamado Pablo não sabe plantar não sabe
tirar leite de vaca Pablo agora lá vem o
Pablo com leite da vaca não não cola Ô o
nome de voa é Agripino Bastião ó
Jeremias matus lenha o n pelo menos se a
pessoa não for antiga o nome pelo menos
não é antigo ó Itamar Itamar que você
fala o nome Itamar Eu já imagino o cara
com a espingarda nas costas já é o casal
vó tem que ter nome de vó Andrea só fo
almoço não cara Andrea ó neid neid nunca
queimou um bolo na vida dela neid porque
o nome sustenta neid